suis venu à genève pour refaire son
pursuit tech24 aux discussions
et pour parler des questions de sécurité
européenne notre objectif était de
déterminer si la russie était prête à
adopter une voie diplomatique et
d'autres afin de désescalade et la
situation en ukraine désamorcer la crise
en ukraine et résoudre nos différends
grâce à la diplomatie et au dialogue
les discussions avec monsieur lavrov
aujourd'hui on était des échanges francs
et concret
j'ai présenté la présence de la position
des états unis nous sommes fermement aux
côtés de l'ukraine pour promouvoir sa
souveraineté et son intégrité
territoriale tout comme nos voisins de
l'union européenne nous avons été reçus
1.6 les forces russes on y traverse la
frontière se soit qualifiée d' invasion
et ce sera
suivie d'une réponse d'une riposte
rapide des états unis et de ses alliés
nous savons qu'une expérience que la
russie a toujours un agenda d'
avec des attaques cyber des petites
escarmouches des petites attaques et
d'autres moyens pour à faire avant
progresser agressivement c'est
intéressant d'utiliser des actions
militaires ces types d'agressions russes
feront également l'objet de riposte
calibré et d'une réponse unie et unifiée
voilà le message clair qui
le message clair que j'ai décidé de
présenter après mes échanges avec le
heureux président ukrainien après mes
échanges avec les différents
représentants européens nous sommes unis
nous sommes prêts à trouver une solution
grâce à la diplomatie et au dialogue
mais nous sommes également déterminés à
imposer des conséquences ferme si la
russie choisi la confrontation et le
conflit j'ai présenté à monsieur lavrov
le fait que concernant les questions de
sécurité présentée par la russie ces
dernières semaines les états unis et nos
alliés et partenaires européens sont
prêts à poursuivre des
moyen de résolution dans un esprit de
réciprocité en cela signifie que la
russie doit également répondre à nos
préoccupations
plusieurs étapes sont possibles
plusieurs mesures y compris à prendre
par là aussi pour améliorer la
transparence pour réduire les risques
pour promouvoir le contrôle des armes et
pour renforcer la relation de confiance
j'ai parlé à monsieur la broche et
juillet est même si la prof et je lui
parlais des préoccupations liées à
l'intervention russe en ukraine et dans
toute l'europe et dans le monde entier
d'ailleurs j'ai lu également présenté
quelques idées pour réduire les tensions
et renforcer la sécurité nous que nous
avons développée en consultation avec
nos partenaires et alliés et nous
pensons que nous pouvons trouver un
terrain d'entente sur la base du
principe de réciprocité
cela n'aide ce n'était pas une
négociation mais un échange honnête de
préoccupation et d'idées j'ai très
clairement exprimés or un monsieur
lavrov qu'il y a des principes
fondamentaux que les états unis et ses
alliés sont prêts à défendre cela inclut
la protection
la protection des ukrainiens qui doivent
déterminer leur propre avenir c'est une
ligne rouge à ne pas franchir
monsieur lavrov et moi avant est
également parlé de l'avenir
ils le
il m'a entendu dire que ce qui est pour
nous une règle
il ya une règle très importante referee
rien sur l'europe sans l'europe rien sur
le temps sans l'otan rien sur l'ukraine
sans l'ukraine alors sur la base de nos
échanges
je pense qu'il est possible de
promouvoir
notre compréhension mutuelle afin
d'assurer notre sécurité respectives
mais il y a un besoin le besoin que la
russie arrête avait agressé l'ukraine
voilà le choix de la russie peut choisir
la voie de la diplomatie qui mène vers
la paix et la sécurité la stabilité ou
la voie qui mène vers le conflit les
conséquences graves et une condamnation
internationale
les états unis et nos alliés et
partenaires en europe sont prêts à eau
affronter la russie sur n'importe quel
chemin et nous sommes prêts à soutenir
l'ukraine monsieur lavrov comprend à
présent mieux quelle est notre position
et inversement les échanges aujourd'hui
ont été utiles à cet égard et c'est
précisément la raison pour laquelle nous
avons décidé de nous rencontrer nous je
vais retourner à washington cet après
midi pour retrouver le président d'en
bas donné notre équipe de sécurité
nationale ainsi que des membres du
congrès et nos alliés et partenaires
dans les jours à venir sur la base des
échanges d'aujourd'hui le monsieur
lavrov et moi avons décidé qu'il était
important que le processus diplomatique
continue l'éco centre sultats sion
formelle que nous aurons su que je
tiendrais les jours à venir avec nos
alliés et partenaires nous nous
attendons à ce que nous serons en mesure
de partager avec la russie nos
préoccupations et nos idées avec plus de
détails sous forme écrite d'ici la
semaine prochaine et nous sommes
convenus d'avoir de nouveaux échanges
après cela
d'autres discussions diplomatiques
seraient la meilleure marche à suivre
nous sommes d'accord là dessus mais une
fois de plus il appartient à la russie
de décider quel chemin elle souhaite
emprunter
je dois également dire que monsieur
l'avoir fait moi avons eu l'occasion de
parler comment les états unis et la
russie peuvent travailler ensemble sur
les questions de sécurité liées à des
présentations partager les rôles le
respect des accords de vienne nous avons
eu nous sommes arrivés à un moment très
important si cet accord est un accord
n'est pas conclu dans les semaines à
venir sur lui eh bien il sera impossible
de retrouver le traité de vienne mais il
y a encore une possibilité d'avancer une
possibilité est de réussir c'est de
voir ces négociations couronnées de
succès nous ne nous attendions pas à ce
qu'il y ait de grandes avancées
aujourd'hui mais je pense que nous
sommes sur la bonne voie pour
comprendre les préoccupent nos
préoccupations mutuelles l'opposition
mutuelle et voir ce qui va se produire à
l'avenir et sur ce je suis prêt à
répondre à vos questions
merci monsieur blinken
monsieur lavrov a à parler aujourd'hui
d'une rhétorique hystérique a comme il
la qualifie de la part de l'occident
concernant une invasion
le président biden a déclaré que
il qu'il pense que poutine avant ça car
il doit faire quelque chose
à ce jour avez vous une meilleure
compréhension
grâce à monsieur lavrov des intentions
du président poutine avez vous reçu des
engagements
des engagements concernant la
l'interruption des agressions de la
russie il déclare que vous allez
présenter monsieur lavoie fable déclaré
que vous alliez présenter des réponses
écrites mais il souhaite que ce soit des
réponses à ces propositions que vous et
votre administration ont déclaré dès le
début n'était n'était pas raisonnable
alors dans vos réponses est-ce que vos
réponses écrites
vont parler de l'expansion de l'otan
qui est non négociable
ou
ou y at-il une possibilité de désamorcer
cette crise et vous avez à parler de
l'iran pensez vous qu'il est possible de
parler à monsieur lavrov
et de faire en sorte que vous les
etats-unis la russie les autres alliés
trouve à un accord en fasse en sorte que
l'iran respecte le traité les accords de
vienne et que les états unis lèvent
leurs sanctions
alors tout d'abord nous ne travaillons
pas sur la base des émotions mais sur la
base des faits et de l'histoire
les faits sont les suivants la russie a
amassé énormément de force à la
frontière ukrainienne et continuent à le
faire
des centaines de milliers de soldats
russes récemment y compris des forces
déployées en biélorussie ce qui
permettrait à la russie si le président
poutine le choisit
d'attaquer l'ukraine depuis le sud et
l'est le nord
et nous avons un de taille revue les
projets pour chercher à déstabiliser le
pays
déstabiliser le pays pour renverser le
gouvernement différent différents plans
alors comme je les dis nous ne
travaillons pas sur la base d' émotion
mais sur la base de faits et sur la base
de l'histoire aux jeux
la russie a envahi l'ukraine en 2014
s'est emparé de la crimée a entraîné un
conflit
aura dans le donbass en asie d'ukraine
de l'est voilà ce qui nous intéresse
voilà ce que nous observons nous avons
entendu les représentants russes dire
qu'ils n'ont pas l'intention d'envahir
l'ukraine
monsieur lavrov me l'a répété
aujourd'hui d'ailleurs
ceci étant une fois de plus
nous regardons ce qui est visible
visible à aux yeux de tous les faits les
actes et pas les paroles
je les dis monsieur lavrov si la russie
souhaite chercher à convaincre le monde
je ne souhaite pas agresser l'ukraine un
bon début ce consisterait à
désamorcer la crise a rapatrié ces
masses soldats
postés à la frontière
et travailler avec diplomatie dans le
dialogue que nous avons fait aujourd'hui
ce que nous avons l'intention de
continuer à faire dans les jours et
semaines à venir
nous l'avons toujours dit
nous souhaitons répondre aux
préoccupations présentées par là aussi
mais nous souhaitons également présenter
nos préoccupations il y en a beaucoup
concernant les actes de la russie que
nous considérons comme des menaces pour
la sécurité en europe et au delà
et donc il était important dans le cadre
de nos échanges au jeu duy
et la semaine dernière
au conseil
il était important de nous assurer que
nous comprenons clairement une
opposition nos préoccupations mutuelles
après cela et après nous a entretenus en
avec nos alliés et nos partenaires
le président byden souhaité que je
rencontre monsieur lavrov après avoir
digéré les informations reçues et
j'imagine que la russie a également eu
l'occasion de discuter de ce qu'ils ont
entendu notre part avec le résident
poutine pour réellement voir où nous en
sommes directement avec le avec monsieur
lavrov pour déterminer s'il y a une voix
une voix pour le dialogue et la
diplomatie et ensuite pour voir comment
nous pouvons faire un premier pas dans
cette voie c'est ce que nous avons fait
aujourd'hui et nous allons
partager nos réponses aux préoccupations
présentées par là aussi nous allons
présenter nos propres préoccupations
également et nous allons proposer
quelques idées à étudier nous avons
ensuite l'intention de nous retrouver
une fois que la russie aura eu
l'occasion de lire nos réponses par
écrit et nous verrons où nous en sommes
à ce moment là mais je tiens à être
clair sur un point
pour le moment la russie travaille avec
diplomatie mais en parallèle le pays
continue à
exacerber la crise a amassé des troupes
à la frontière ukrainienne continue à
prévoir des actions violentes contre
l'ukraine s'il est bien nous et nos
partenaires et alliés sont également
prêts à nous assurer que
nous sommes prêts à exprimer clairement
à la russie que il y aura une riposte
claire cv réunis à toute forme
d'agression par la russie contre
l'ukraine
enfin sur la base de nos échanges
aujourd'hui je pense qu'il y à des
domaines
où de manière réciproque nous pouvons
répondre à nos préoccupations mutuelles
pour cela va de la plus de transparence
dans nos activités une plus grande
réduction des risques chercher à
contrôler les armes et d'autres manières
de renforcer la confiance qui
permettrait de répondre à certaines des
préoccupations exprimées par la russie
ainsi qu'à de bons nombres de nos
propres préoccupations toutefois il est
très important d'être est également
clair sur ce que nous n'allons pas faire
par exemple nous n'allons pas revenir
sur les principes fondamentaux
que nous avons et que nous sommes prêts
à défendre
un de ses fondamentaux et la politique
de la porte ouverte de l'otan et j'ai
également parlé ces derniers jours et
ces dernières semaines de notre
engagement
envers un principe qu' on ne peut pas
imposer un pays ses choix en matière de
sécurité
et un pays ne peut pas exercer une
sphère d'influencé qui subjugue rey qui
a imposé sa volonté à un autre un autre
et à
ses principes restent fermes ne
reviendrai pas là dessus et je pense que
la russie l'a très bien compris alors
une fois de plus sur la base de nos
échanges aujourd'hui où ces dernières
semaines est ici aujourd'hui à genève je
pense que
nous avons les moyens de répondre à
certaines de nos préoccupations
concernant la sécurité nous verrons
s'il est nos échanges ont porté leurs
fruits et en parallèle nous allons
continuer à nous préparer
avec détermination
peu importe le choix que fera la russie
inde de l'agression de la confrontation
et des conséquences ou de la diplomatie
et du dialogue
laquelle concernant l'iran
alors sur l'iran je dois dire que la
russie partagent notre sentiment
d'urgence le besoin de voir si les
s'il est possible de retrouver un
certain niveau de conformité dans les
semaines à venir
et nous espérons que la russie utilisera
l'influent ce qu'elle a et la relation
qu'elle a avec les rangs afin de
lui communiquer ce sentier ce sentiment
d'urgence et si nous ne sommes pas en
mesure de le faire parce que l'iran
refuse
de
prendre les mesures nécessaires
eh bien nous adopterons une autre
approche afin de gérer le danger
représenté par le nouveau programme
nucléaire iranien ce programme qui a été
mis en boîte grâce à aux accords le
jesse piret les accords de vienne et qui
malheureusement aujourd'hui un programme
qui malheureusement aujourd'hui s'est
échappé à cause de notre retrait de
l'accord et du la reprise par l'iran de
ce programme
merci monsieur blinken
après quatre réunions entre les
diplomates américains et russes est ce
que ce processus doit passer au niveau
présidentiel afin d'avancer est ce que
le président biden doit rencontrer le
président poutine pour que des progrès
soient réellement fait deuxième question
à berlin vous avez a présenté les enjeux
de cette crise y compris la sécurité
pour la sentinelle le caractère sacré et
des frontières esque et pourtant le
prétend baden il ya quelques semaines
déclaré que l'utilisation des forces
militaires américaines n'était pas une
possibilité
alors c'est logique pour certains
américains mais pourriez-vous expliquer
les arguments pourquoi cette
alternative a été supprimée et que
feriez vous si la russie allait envahir
l'ukraine
est ce que cet engagement entre
tiendrait alors tout d'abord sur la
seconde partie de votre question
nous avons exprimé très clairement et
nous avons fait des choses très
clairement pour montrer notre soutien
envers l'ukraine et nous allons
continuer à le faire
tout d'abord nous travaillons en étroite
collaboration avec nos alliés et nos
partenaires afin de développer de
présenter très clairement quelles
seraient les conséquences d'une invasion
russe en ukraine
c'était une composante importante
qui consista à dissuader la russie de ce
d'adopter cette approche mais en
parallèle
nous avons fourni à ukraine
d'importants une importante assistance
militaire de défense
plus que jamais depuis 2014 alors nous
continuons à leur apporter cette aide
militaire nos alliés nos partenaires en
font de même et enfin nous travaillons
en étroite collaboration avec nos alliés
et nos partenaires pour commencer à
planifier le renforcement de l'otan elle
même sur son front
en cas d'agression russe contre
l'ukraine
tout cela pour montrer clairement à la
russie qu'il y aurait des coûts et des
conséquences a eu des actions
potentielles nous pensons que c'est la
meilleure manière la manière la plus
efficace de convaincre la russie de ne
pas poursuivre ses actions agressives
contre l'ukraine l'ukraine est un
partenaire très important pour les
etats-unis
et pour d'autres pays en europe
également
toutefois notre engagement à l'article 5
implique les alliés de l'otan
c'est quelque chose qui nous tient
énormément à coeur l'ukraine n'est pas
membre de l'otan donc n'est pas couvert
par l'engagement de l'article 5
toutefois nous sommes déterminés à faire
tout ce qui est en notre pouvoir pour
défendre ce pays et pour empêcher une à
toute agression et comme je le dis nous
allons continuer pour suivre tous nos
efforts dans les jours et semaines à
venir même alors que nous cherchons à
emprunter un chemin de dialogue et de
diplomatie et j'ai oublié la première
partie de votre question le dialogue
entre le président bayonnais le
président poutine pour faire plus de
progrès
aujourd'hui nous sommes convenus d'une
chose
nous allons partager par écrit la
semaine prochaine
nos idées
nos réponses aux préoccupations
présentées par la russie les
préoccupations que nous allons à nouveau
réitéré dans notre courrier
sur la base de nos échanges aujourd'hui
sur la base
de ce document et du document que nous
avons reçu de la russie nous allons à
avoir d'autres rencontres je dois autre
rencontre
au niveau des ministres des affaires
étrangères tout d'abord et si cela
s'avère utile et productif
que nos présidents se rencontre pourrait
essayer de faire avancer la situation eh
bien je pense que nous sommes tout à
fait prêts à le faire le président biden
a déjà rencontré le président poutine
ici à genève et il
lui a parlé par visioconférence au
téléphone à de nombreuses reprises
et si nous et les russes pensons que la
meilleure manière de résoudre le
problème est d'avoir une conversation
entre nos présidents et bien nous sommes
tout à fait prêts à organiser cet
événement
vous continuer à dialoguer dispute avec
les russes et il continue à agir il
continue à amasser hamas et des soldats
pour la frontière ukrainienne
vous nous avez reconnu les dégâts qu'ils
ont déjà causé à cause des relations
alors pourquoi ne pas penser à des
sanctions
ils craignent les a demandé et
américains nous ont demandés et deuxième
question vous avez été à de nombreuses
reprises que la russie
attaque l'ukraine avec des prétextes
monsieur lavoie préface à vous et vous
ment éhontément alors
allez vous parler de ce mensonge dans
votre réponse la semaine prochaine
alors tout d'abord nous n'attendons pas
pour agir contre la russie comme je
viens de le dire nous nous sommes
engagés à offrir plus d aide militaire à
la russie
659 dollars plus que jamais on revient
2014 quand la russie a envahi l'ukraine
il ya d'autres actions qui sont en
retraite nous avons également travaillé
à travers le monde par voie diplomatique
pour à mobiliser nos alliés nos
partenaires pour faire face à la menace
russe contre l'ukraine hier nous avons
annoncé des actions contre les agents
d'influencé étrangères en ukraine post
en ukraine et qu'ils cherchent à
déstabiliser le pays nous avons exprimé
clairement à la russie que le pays
ferait face à des conséquences graves
s'il souhaite continuer à envahir
une graine à poursuivre leurs menaces
contre l'ukraine et nous avons également
parlé de notre volonté de renforcer le
flanc est de l'otan nous travaillons par
voie diplomatique le dialogue c'est le
monde travaille toutefois en parallèle
nous préparons notre défense et notre
dissuasion ce n'est pas incompatible ces
deux approches se renforce et donc nous
parlons mais si les russes continuent à
renforcer la crise eh bien nous
continuons à nous renforcer en apportant
une aide à l'ukraine par exemple pour
assurer sa défense nous travaillons
également au sein de l'otan pour nous
préparer à renforcer l'organisation et
nous continuons également
définir et à affiner quelles seront les
conséquences graves pour la russie avec
nos alliés et nos partenaires nous
qu'elles soient économiques financières
ou autres
donc nous faisons les deux en parallèle
concernant les conversations que nous
tenons
je pense qu'une bonne interprétation une
interprétation sympathique et que
parfois nous avons différentes
interprétations d'une histoire les
etats-unis et la russie et je dois dire
qu'aujourd'hui
nous avons entendu des choses
avec lesquelles nous ne sommes pas du
tout d'accord
concernant l'histoire et son
interprétation les dans l'ensemble les
échanges
étaient admis qu elle était direct franc
et je pense que à cet égard il était
utile
et il est important de voir si une fois
de plus nous pouvons résoudre ces
différends par le biais de la diplomatie
et du dialogue ce qui bien évidemment la
voie la plus responsable mais il
appartient la russie de choisir une
dernière question
alors je tenais à vous parler des
mesures pour désamorcer la crise vous en
avait déjà parlé un petit peu des deux
côtés pourriez-vous donner plus de
détails et nous parler un petit peu du
calendrier qu'est ce qui doit être fait
d'abord et que pensez vous que le
kremlin souhaite
alors cette dernière question est
probablement une question à poser au
président poutine
il n'y a que lui qui sache ce qu'il soit
de faire et je reviens dans une minute
mais comme je le disais précédemment je
pense que
nous nous sommes penchés sur ce qu'a
proposé la russie nous avons écouté ce
que la russie avait à dire
entre plus avec nos alliés et nos
partenaires
nous nous sommes penchés sur nos propres
préoccupations en matière de sécurité
face aux exactions de la russie contre
l'ukraine mais également dans d'autres
régions du monde et avec d'autres moyens
en europe et au delà
je pense que l'on peut justement de dire
qu'il ya des domaines où nous pensons
qu'il est possible de
poursuivre le dialogue avec des premiers
afin de voir s'il ya moyen de répondre à
nos préoccupations liées à la sécurité
mutuelle pour renforcer la sécurité pour
tous pour nous pour nos alliés et
partenaires européens et pour la russie
est comme gelée suggéré précédemment
la transparence
les mesures pour renforcer la confiance
des manoeuvres militaires à du contrôle
des accords sur le contre les armes
voilà des choses que nous avons fait par
le peu de choses que nous avons faites
par le passé et qui ont
et qu'ils peuvent à mon sens
réduire les tensions et répondre aux
préoccupations
une fois de plus
il faut il faut voir
attendre et voir si c'est possible et
cela dépend évidemment
cela dépend évidemment de ce que la
russie souhaite faire
voilà la bonne question
et j'en ai parlé à monsieur lavaud
aujourd'hui quelque chose qui m'a
particulièrement frappé je lui ai posé
la question suivante du point de vue de
la russie
je lui ai demandé qu il explique qu'il
m'explique à moi à nous
comment ils considèrent les actions
à tapoter les actions qu'ils ont brisée
et en quoi les actions prises en
renforçant la sécurité comme je l'aï dit
à monsieur lavrov
vous avez fait beaucoup de choses ces
dernières années
qui ont
entraîné tout ce que vous souhaitiez
éviter
avant que la russie n'envahisse
l'ukraine en 2014 s'empare de la crimée
s'attaque au donbass
il y avait 70% de pourcentage favorable
à la russie en ukraine maintenant c'est
moins de 30% avant 2014 avant qu'ils
s'emparent de la crimée et avant qu'il
n'ait le soutien pour lui leur pays pour
rejoindre
l'otan c'était environ 20% maintenant
c'est 60%
avant 2014
et nous travaillons
nous cherchons à réduire
tout en renforçant nos forces on en
europe depuis la fin de la guerre froide
et bien après 2014 l'otan à se sentir
obligé à cause de l'agression riche
obligé de renforcer ses forces
militaires sur son no flanc oriental et
depuis 2014 nos efforts pour convaincre
nos alliés et nos partenaires à
accroître leurs dépenses en matière d
essence ont fonctionné à ce match
et ce n'est pas à cause de ce que nous
avons fait c'est à cause des actions et
de la russie donc
en quoi les actions de la russie
permettent d'atténuer ses préoccupations
on voit que les faits 1 c'est l'effet
inverse qui s'est produit f aujourd'hui
si la russie continue d'agresser et
l'ukraine les résultats seront et bien
un renforcement un renforcement
des forces armées qui préoccupe autant
la russie alors j'espère que c'est
quelque chose
que monsieur lavrov comprendra et que
monsieur poutine comprendra également et
auquel ils penseront dans les jours à
venir merci